so we looked at the formal definition of
what it means for a sequence to converge
but as a practical matter how can we
tell whether a given sequence converges
or not there are two criteria that are
the most commonly used for that purpose
and it's useful to be aware of them the
first one deals with the case where we
have a sequence of numbers that keep
increasing or at least they do not go
down in that case those numbers may go
up forever without any bound so if you
look at any particular value there's
going to be a time at which the sequence
has exceeded that value in that case we
say that the sequence converges to
infinity but if this is not the case if
it does not converge to infinity which
means that the entries of the sequence
are bounded they do not grow arbitrarily
large then in that case it is guaranteed
that the sequence would converge to a
certain number this is not something
that we will attempt to prove but it is
a useful fact to know another way of
establishing convergence is to derive
some bounds on the distance of our
sequence from the number that we suspect
to be the limit if that distance becomes
smaller and smaller if we can manage to
bound that distance by a certain number
and that number goes down to zero then
it is guaranteed that since this
distance goes down to zero that the
sequence ái converges to a and there's a
variation of this argument which is the
so-called sandwich argument and it goes
as follows if we have a certain sequence
that converges to some number a and we
have another sequence that converges to
that same number
and our sequence is somewhere in between
then our sequence must also converge to
that particular number a so these are
the usual ways of quickly saying
something about the convergence of a
given sequence and we will be often
using this type of argument in this
class but without making a big fuss
about them or without even referring to
these facts in an explicit manner